Speaker 1: Lindsey Graham is now threatening
riots if Donald Trump is indicted.
Now, this is being reported as Lindsey Graham
predicts riots if Donald Trump gets indicted.
But the reality is that Lindsey Graham is
threatening the riots. It's his followers
who would be doing the rioting. Now, Lindsey
could say right wingers would never do that,
but he's not saying that. Right wingers is saying
our side will riot in the street if Donald Trump
is indicted and it is indeed a threat. Check this
out. This is an interview that Lindsey gave to
Fox News over the weekend. Very, very quickly,
garnering millions of views and understand
this is a threat. He is saying you'd better
not do it. And I'm going to give you the two
reasons why he's saying this. Say this. If there
is a prosecution of Donald Trump for mishandling
classified information after the Clinton debacle,
which you presided over and did a hell of a good
job, there'll be riots in the streets, right?
There will be riots in the streets. Now, first and
foremost, I thought right wingers never rioted.
Remember, it was BLM that does the rioting. It
was Antifa that does the rioting. It might have
even been people pretending to be Trumpists,
but really left wingers on January six who were
dressed up as Trumpists and had Trump stuff on
their social media dating back years, but it was
all a ruse. They were really left wingers because
right wingers would never, ever, ever riot. And
now Lindsey is saying there will be riots if Trump
is indicted. This is what they do. Lindsey is
planting the seeds when he says, I predict that
there might be riots. He is getting right wingers
to think about what will we do if there is an
indictment of Trump? Now, when we learned about
the search warrant being served at Mar a Lago,
Trump started showing up in large groups at Mar
a Lago and elsewhere, and it didn't get violent,
fortunately, but it was very clear that they are
willing to get out there in the real world. Well,
now you've got Lindsey saying, I predict
that there will be. Right. Really, Lindsey,
who will be doing it? It's not going to be
Black Lives Matter Antifa. It's going to be
Trumpists. So they are now planting the seed. Now
afterwards, they might say it was Antifa anyway.
You know, they love these dystopian headlines.
Portland, Oregon has been eliminated from the map
after antifa detonated a suitcase nuke that never.
What are you talking about? That never happened.
Portland's fine. Portland's still there. And
so here's the goal of what Lindsey Graham
is saying. There's two purposes to Lindsey Graham
coming out and saying this. The first purpose is
if we start sending a signal to the Justice
Department that it will get very violent and
very hectic and very riotous and dystopian in
the streets of America. If Trump is indicted,
maybe we can prevent an indictment altogether.
So that's like the priority number one would be
maybe I can start sending these signals and
Trump won't get indicted at all. The Justice
Department might say there's too much fallout,
there's too much risk. We're not going to do it.
The second part of it, of course, is the obvious
one, which is start to get the political allies
and the right wingers comfortable with the idea
that it would be correct for there to be violence
in the streets. Because if people like Lindsey
and others start saying this would be so unfair,
this would be so bad, this would be so improper
if Trump were to be indicted, that it would
obviously lead to riots in the streets.
They're essentially normalizing the rioting
and whether the idea there is to maybe prevent
the right wingers from getting in as much trouble
as they did after January six or whatever
the point is start to normalize the idea
that if this happened, violence would
be appropriate. That is another element
of this. It's the Catholic terrorism in a way
which we've talked about before. They're really
buried dangerously on the line of straight up
encouraging the violence. But understand that
the headline is B.S. The headline, Lindsey Graham
predicts violence. No, no, no. Lindsey Graham is
threatening violence. Lindsey Graham is promising
violence and he seems to be saying it would be
justified. And that's an extraordinarily scary
place to be when one of one sitting senators
is planting the idea of violence in the minds of
a group of people that are willing to do violence
and property destruction and everything
we saw on January six, really scary stuff.
We'll have this clip of Lindsey on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.